[Music]
well hello and welcome to AI the future
of us which is a podcast Style video
series that explores the ways in which
AI is shaping our future and how we can
prepare for the changes that lie ahead
I'm your host Forest Brazil and today
we're joined by farat teckner who is a
product manager at Google Cloud focused
on data and analytics throughout it's
great to have you thanks for being here
today
thank you Forest good to uh good to see
you how are you I'm doing well thank you
well we're going to be talking today
about how AI impacts the future of
business analysts specifically and I
think maybe the best place to start is
to talk a little bit about your
background in this area if you're out so
can you tell us a little bit about your
expertise in the field of data and AI
how did you get into uh the work that
you're doing now
thank you it's it's interesting so uh I
did my PhD and you know many many years
ago in reinforcement learning and you
know AI but no one wanted to pay for my
skills I did my first looks and became
an academic and it's interesting that
you know 20 years ago it was popular but
it wasn't you know in the business area
at all so I moved into data analytics
continuing to do AI as well so I work
with world's largest organizations
helping them to build that you know data
analytics environments and such and then
you know came to Google building you
know interesting products for our
customers
so you're sort of an undercover AI
expert in the field of data which is
perfect for the conversation that we're
having uh so with that said you know
what do you find Most Fascinating about
where we're at in AI right now Pharaoh
maybe especially with the the advances
in generative AI that we've seen over
the last few years what's exciting you
right now
I think the you know one of the
challenges throughout the years is
difficulty on getting the environments
into the Hensel did you know AI
practitioners right so it was very
expensive they were only very few people
can do it and realizing the return on
investments for the organizations were
very difficult right so what we are
seeing now is increased interest because
tools are becoming such that people can
see the benefits of AI in their
day-to-day lives and that's what
generative AI is giving us right so
using something like Bart for example
and writing you know some questions to
it and getting summaries or some
articles is really helping us in terms
of the productivity that will impact
everyone right it is not just going to
be the you know people who are you know
experts in the area but we are really
broadening it and I don't want to use
the Democrat gratization but we are
really democratizing the AI to the
masses as well
yeah well I think you're right on about
that for us and I mean even more than
that you've started to dive into what
does this mean for specific roles right
for specific people even Beyond just
that narrow subset of quote-unquote AI
experts and that leads us right back to
where we started which is with with
business analysts so let's say I'm a
business analyst right now I've been
doing this for a few years you know I've
got established existing workflows how
do you see AI affecting my field in the
next few years what what impact do you
think it's going to have on me
I think it is you know
it is interesting right and I'll start
with a dream my dream is that as a
business analyst you come and what you
have in your mind you just articulate as
a you know nature language
give me the you know the the top 10
products that we sold within the past 10
weeks right it is a typical bi dashboard
at the end of the day imagine coming and
doing it that way and accessing to the
dashboard straight away or the the other
part of this is that you know you don't
really need to go and do the data
engineering the system will build
everything for you and you'll be able to
start using that that doesn't mean that
the data analyst will not be there
because someone really needs to still
look into things like the data quality
the you know whether it is using the
right sources whether it has the most
refreshed data and such as well right
and someone really needs to bring that
contacts and bring that you know
know-how from the business side into
that and articulate what those results
are so the business size will be there
but their productivity will be uplifted
they are not going to spend time on what
are these apis or do they data types
that I need to bring in to be able to
massage this data and show this
dashboard that will be really you know
there'll be a catalyst from the the
generative AI side of things we'll get
to the results faster and we'll spend
more time on activating the business
problems and having more impact to it as
well
yes I I well remember working for a bi
company years ago and wrangling with
their custom DSL and trying to figure
out how to get past that to the
questions that I wanted to ask and
bringing that natural language in is I
think exciting because of the barriers
it can remove right between us and the
interesting questions what do you think
uh I mean alongside of the the
productivity increases right we know
there are potentially some some ethical
considerations to applying automated
intelligence generative AI to some of
the things that business analysts do so
what do you think are some of these
pressing ethical considerations
surrounding the integration of AI with a
business analyst's work
and that's a very good question all
right and that's one of the you know
things that we'll be saying a lot for
example the you know did the robots and
I want to call them the robots right so
I've been explaining this to my
eight-year-olds so she comes with and
you know Daddy how can we build how can
I ask questions and get these results
because I've been telling her about
everything around the bar then chat gb10
such all the world right so and she's
like how can get how can it get me all
of this information you know it's human
beings building the algorithms it is
processing the data and the you know
content that we have been generating
throughout the years and decades and
centuries in a sense which is what we
are feeding into the you know the models
here right so naturally our thinking is
changing throughout the years as well
some of the things that we found you
know maybe acceptable which we are
realizing they are not the right things
and right attitudes anymore because we
are evolving you know systems
unfortunate don't change that way we are
feeding the information as one go right
they are not separating all the you know
information out there on the internet as
a result they come with biases they are
trained on data that can be biased so we
need to be mindful of that also there's
privacy issues as well who owns the data
where the data sources are coming from
right this is an important aspect to it
and transparency is important right so
how did you get to that information how
do I how could I be sure that it is the
correct information as well that you are
displacing the the one thing about the
you know the the inner llms is they are
convincing online as well right the
hallucination that the term that came
from you know Google researchers is you
know is really so convincing when it
gives out the results that you believe
that that's the correct info information
how do you know that this is correct
information or who decides what is
correct or not as well right so we are
going to be seeing challenges around
that a lot no question and of course we
know some of these questions have been
around for a while right bias is not a
new problem in the data world uh you
know making sure you have clean accurate
data has long been a challenge but it
seems like some of these things are
being they're being accelerated they're
being thrust more to the Forefront by
the speed with which we're now able to
produce some of this stuff uh which is
you know both exciting and maybe a
little bit terrifying so the last thing
I want to ask you about is just really
practically
um what are some key skills that I need
as a business analyst to be able to
remain successful to to I don't want to
say AI proof my career exactly but to
continue to stay relevant and uh take
advantage of these things that are
coming out
right so one of the things that I would
stay up to date with the latest
developments right so try understanding
it is a rapidly evolving You Know Field
we'll be seeing a lot more changes it is
like really trying to catch up a very
fast-mowing train if you like right so
try to understand you know what are the
key areas to focus on try to stay up to
date learn about it you know exactly
what you mentioned about the ethical
considerations around you know
surrounding AI as well because we really
want to give the you know the right
answers and develop skills that will be
in demand in the future right AI is
likely to automate some of the jobs but
not everything if you have the right
background if you have the right
foundations you'll be able to articulate
the results that comes out of it if you
may are able to you know put your
understanding and you know your V point
on it you'll be really leading this and
most importantly you know and I remember
one of my first mentors in life telling
me this be open to change be bold it is
not about I know this particular system
anymore systems are going to change but
I know the skills I understand how to
you know uh work with data I understand
how to get the insights and articulate
the insights from the data you know and
be responsible as well AI is going to be
a really powerful tool right we need to
use that responsibly you know these are
the key things you know if you have the
right foundations I think you'll be
succeeding that's how I think it comes
all comes down to responsibility
accountability and Trust doesn't it
always has it always will thank you so
much for joining us today if you're out
it's been incredibly insightful to hear
your thoughts on the impact the
effective use of AI and of course we all
look forward to seeing how AI will
continue to shape the world around us
right and we hope that uh everybody
watching this will be inspired to
embrace its potential and its
opportunity so thank you so much ferrat
have a great rest of your day and thanks
for having me for us thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you